y'a un autre signe de cette mobilisation
de tous les américains à propos de ces
attentats c'est l' enquête le vieil a
demandé aux gens de collaborer et il a
reçu la plus de 32000 message le chiffre
a été rendu public hier sur internet des
messages téléphoniques des témoignages
sur d'éventuelles pistes que pour être
explorées est les policiers alors à
propos de cette enquête
le fbi a essaye surtout de remonter la
trace des kamikazes qui ont tous été
identifiés
regardez par exemple ce reportage sur
l'homme dont on pense qu'ils
conduisaient l'avion qui s'est écrasé en
pennsylvanie
on a remonté sa trace jusqu'en allemagne
et bien entendu à ses proches tombe des
nues gilles marini
tout sourire il danse c'était il y à 18
mois au liban via de samir jarre a
célébré le mariage d'un cousin
ce jeune homme de 26 ans est il déjà un
soldat de la guerre sainte
sait-il qu'il accomplira une mission
suicide en tous les cas il n'en laisse
rien paraître
même auprès de sa famille il est
innocent je ne les jamais élevé dans la
haine
je n'ai jamais fait de mal à une mouche
nous ne sommes pas des extrémistes
saïd samir jara avait quitté le liban il
ya cinq ans pour l'allemagne hambourg il
étudiait l'aéronautique et cela qu'il
aurait rencontré mohammed atta l'un des
pilotes suicide et cela qu'il aurait pu
être recruté ses amis eux non plus n'ont
rien vu et est toujours bonne humeur il
plaisantait le taureau pouvait se moquer
de lui
je peux pas croire qu'il ait pu faire
une chose depuis quelques semaines il
prenait des cours de pilotage en floride
le 11 septembre il emprunte comme simple
passager l'un des avions suicides
le vol 93 qui va s'écraser en
pennsylvanie pour le fbi asiad samir
jarre a été vraisemblablement le pilote
kamikaze